well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Tuesday may the 14th 2019
in our session on entrepreneurship and
Asian high-tech industries I'm really
happy that today we can have a panel of
entrepreneurs who are from South Korea
and who are working in companies that
really are cross border between South
Korea and the u.s. and talk about the
whole kind of cross-border experience in
what Silicon Valley is for entrepreneurs
who are from other places and various
other topics so standing closest to me
is mr. SJ Jung Sun sang young and SJ is
a serial entrepreneur he started
founding companies while he was still in
college he got his undergraduate degree
in business administration and a
master's in human-computer interface
from Yonsei University he is also a
universe user experience designer and a
full-stack developer so in 2015 he
founded a company named sent B in Korea
which is a FinTech international money
transfer service and he stepped down to
become an advisor to sent me and went on
to found a new startup called Apple
which is what he'll talk about today and
Apple is a company that connects Korean
graphic designers and global clients and
the rest of the world so we'll ask SJ to
go first but before we ask you for
prepared remarks want to also introduce
Brian Jin and Brian is the business
operations manager for a Korean startup
company named Yosemite x and brian is
the finance manager and lead product as
a product designer at Yosemite X he got
his BA in economics from that school
across the bay so here in the US and he
was the first employee to join the
founder of the company YT Kim
and to blockchain court engineers so
he's been deeply involved in product
development and LED product marketing
functions for the company which has a
first ever public blockchain without a
native cryptocurrency
attached so he's working on building
enterprise adoption of this Yosemite
public blockchain we'll talk more about
that as we go along
first of all SJ let me ask you to give
some prepared remarks and we can sit
down either here over here and take the
audience so we can see the slides that's
great that's not yours that's right so
hi I'm miss Jiang and I'm CEO of Apple
my wife is a PhD candidate in
comparative literature and since it's a
study of comparing literature from
multiple countries it is very important
to physically be there to do the
research in those countries and these
are the countries me and my wife will be
staying just in this year it's about ten
long-distance flights and the longest
period I stay in one place is about two
months today I would like to talk about
how I found it two setups while
traveling around the world I came to the
United States when in 2014 with my wife
when she studied the ph.d program in the
University of Illinois I was working as
a freelancer web developer at that time
and I made good enough money doing it so
the experience of working from home gave
me the confidence that I could survive
anyplace if I am with my laptop and also
that was how I was able to come
following my wife without any tangible
plan also I always believed that the
remote
could work ever so I found it a startup
called stampy in 2015 with two
co-founders in Korea remotely Sampey is
a fin tech company that offers cheaper
easier and faster international money
transfer service I led the product
development with engineers and designers
as a co-president and we worked as a
remote team but there was no problem
delivering the product and also
improving the product however
FinTech area was more compliant really
had more compromise related issues than
product related issues one of the
difficulties to run a start-up in South
Korea is the regulatory barriers in
Korea everything that is not explicitly
allowed in the law is considered to be
illegal according to the media more than
half of globally successful 100 startups
you cannot do you cannot even start in
South Korea and it includes Airbnb uber
and then financial from China especially
for uber Korea is famous as a market
that uber didn't even stand a chance
Sanpei also had to go through this long
tunnel of compliance issues and we had
to shut down our service for more than
six months and they seriously limited
the opportunity and contribution we can
give as a product group and since I was
in the United States and I was leading
the product there wasn't much I can do
for the campaign to proceed to the front
and that's why I decided to step down
and move on to my next journey
however for me remote work gave me an
ultimate freedom it allowed me to stay
with the love of my life and still build
a great product and growing business
I thought remote work could solve other
people's problem as well so I tried to
find some other problems to solve with
remote for one Korea is known for its
high passion to the education for
because of that there are many highly
educated professionals in many areas
however the fundamental problem in
Korean industry is that it's too smooth
as a market usually it is told that it
should be over 100 million population to
be self-sufficient but Korea is only
half Korea's Korean population is only
half of that and it is even decreasing
right now as a result professionals in
Korea usually do not do not get
compensated enough for their capability
and the only alternative for them is to
go abroad and usually it is to the state
and that's why I found it helpful with
again two co-founders and again remotely
Apple is a remote based platform that
connects Korean designers and global
clients that have designees we also
provide collaboration tools there is
tailored for design related
communication Korea has a huge pool of
college-educated designers who do not
have enough opportunity in their career
path and average salary is barely over
$20,000 on the other hand in the United
States good designers are very difficult
to find and it's
to work with market size of all graphic
design in the United States is about 15
billion and if you even if you narrow it
down to only after thing it's about 1
billion
so if remote cooperation for design
works very well it could be a perfect
arbitrage to leverage and for that to be
possible it is crucial to have
well-defined job description and
well-managed communication tools Oppo
builds design system as a shell
guideline with client and we use it for
the reference for the future design and
we also provide for the project
management tool and image based
connotation tools for effective
communication what Apple is trying to
achieve in the design area it is
expanded it is possible to extend it to
more tip more areas and more countries
actually it is not hard to find
Indian developers or Ukrainian designers
in from outsourcing platform like upward
even in these days
also many bay area startups founded by
experts
they are already leveraging remote world
by building an engineering team back in
their home countries and it's much more
cost efficient so remote work is the new
normal
Apple itself is a 100% remote team and
six of us are living in four different
cities it also allows us to have
presence in multiple countries and we
have Korean cooperation to be able to
utilize government grant and this is one
of uniqueness of Korea startup ecosystem
Korean store iveco system is heavily
driven by government directly or
indirectly government funds contribute
to the venture capital ours as limited
partners and they also grant stipends
directly to the startup as well where
there are pros and cons on the way they
are supporting the ecosystem it's not a
smart move if you don't take their money
even if you can as an only stage startup
with tight budget we were able to stay
in the Bay Area for two months to meet
potential clients thanks to a government
Korean Korean government program that
supports Korean startups to go abroad
also we are under the process of
incorporating the u.s. in copious
cooperation as well it's reasonable for
us to have us cooperation since we are
dealing with Korea's clients as well so
one dilemma we are trying to find the
answer to is how to set the relationship
between Korean cooperation and the u.s.
cooperation if the u.s. cooperation
becomes a headquarter the government
grant we can receive from Korean
government will be eliminated and if the
Korean cooperation becomes a headquarter
it's not easy to fundraise from the US
specifically the valley investors which
will be crucial for long-term court
being performant when working remotely
made it possible for me to fund my
second startup while living abroad and
now it's outpost vision to allow lead
people to work across border without any
limitation when you think of uber or a
baby just a few years ago everyone has
to who'd let strangers in your house or
in your car but nobody asks that
questions anymore
so here's the question do you think
people can work as a team even if they
are not in the same office thank you
thanks SJ so let me get the other
presentation set up and ask you a
question
so right now how do you attract new
designers to be kind of working with
Apple how do you get new people to use
the platform so right now we are using
private both private channels and public
channels so one of our co-founders is
Korean designer and she's trying to let
her friends in into the pool so that we
could work with them and also we are
looking for many many open bulletin
boards and many common online
communities so that they could know us
and start working with us okay
and while you're here in the Bay Area
you have an office in plug-and-play
right now yeah we do be okay the program
of sempre okay okay so good that's great
for now we'll come back we'll have
additive chances to ask more and talk
more about your companies for now I'd
like to ask Brian to come up and talk to
us about Yosemite x floors yours thank
you
oh my name is Brian thanks for having me
dr. Becher yeah so I'm from a start-up
in Palo Alto
we're located our offices down on
University Avenue and we're watching a
startup company and our founder is from
Korea with you know focus on developing
a solution for a lot of enterprise and
business use cases on what they can do
with the blockchain as a technology
without all the hypes
of or now that all the hypes about the
cryptocurrencies and everything has died
down we're trying to bring the real use
cases to make entreprise solutions for
businesses to use the technology so yeah
so you send me X we've were founded in
2013 when our founder whitey Kim he had
the idea of bringing the he's from he
used to working in the entertainment
business in Korea and you know he had an
idea of you know creating this like a
middlemen less distribution channel for
music distribution so music industry so
that he worked with you know two
different blockchain engineers that to
create this system where they can
actually connect the producers and the
you know the audience directly and this
idea when we were still in the beginning
stages got in touch with Shawn Fanning
who is the co-founder of Napster and you
know he took himself is like a very much
of like a musician so he he took very
serious interest in what we had going so
he actually met with whitey to invite
him to come over to Silicon Valley and
start our business here and you know
that's when I met him after I graduated
from the big college across the bay was
that you know like we were just getting
started in terms of you know setting our
player base in Palo Alto trying to tap
into the brightest minds
of you know what they what the barrier
has to offer and you know where the
center of the technological innovations
are happening we want to take advantage
of such an opportunity to basically test
out and compete against I guess with
what the best has to offer so that's
when we started and working in the
United States in trying to develop a
blockchain solution to figure out how to
best distribute the music and all the
other informational transfer and what we
ran into is the fact that we try to
build off of the existing technologies
using aetherium eos if you guys are
familiar with the blockchain as a
technology but we were soon faced with
the limitations of what the current
technology has to offer in terms of
bring in like a viable solution to the
market so we decided to actually you
know pause on our initial goal and
actually trying to solve the matter more
directly by developing the underlying
blocking technology first in order to
create this cryptocurrency less
blockchain so that we can actually
utilize a tool for what it is instead of
having getting mixed up with like the
you know the disaster of the rely on
insulin that cañedo cryptocurrency
which is making the entire network to
volatile for any actual usages so we
spent you know the last couple years
developing our own blocking protocol
which we have finished and is called
Yosemite public blockchain and it is
open domain that in itself is up and
running right now I mean if you consider
this you can consider this as like a
equivalent of like Internet when it
first came out you know the Internet
itself is a network but then it is up
and running it connects people accounts
and what we thought it needs to do is
have like a better of like a use case of
actual you know you know just like how
internet had search engines emails blogs
or you know other use cases services
that are being built on top of the
underlying network
so using new public blockchain is like
an equivalent of like an Internet what
we've built is the ecosystem where a lot
of the services can utilize the
potential that it has the unique thing
about it I guess is the fact that we
don't have a cryptocurrency
native cryptocurrency so it's not
reliant on like a theorem Bitcoin and
therefore you know we don't have to be
subjected to the price volatility aspect
of the server costs and things like that
and speaking of these services that
could be built on top of it is why we
developed the asymmetry cart which is
pretty much the first real viable
solution that anybody can actually use
the blockchain technology for in order
to have a real service that they can
attach you know use we're we're working
with rolling that out towards you know
later this month actually it's like a
first official launch of it so that we
were able to utilize blotching in order
to connect individual accounts and
provide better payment service between
the customer and the merchants these are
the standard credit card or so it's not
it's not it's different than like a
static credit card in a sense
the utility I guess would be very much
similar but it's going to be different
from it fundamentally because it's one
the idea of using blockchain is to
bypass all the intermediary services
that includes you know the Visa
MasterCard as well as all the payment I
just gateways of facilitators so that
we're able to connect you know if I'm
paying you then you would get money
directly from me instead of me and to go
through like multiple channels in order
to send that payment across okay um so
it's literally just taking the the the
utility of what blocking as a technology
can offer and making the use case out of
it and the along the way what we've you
know experienced is basically our
founder he's from Korea and even though
we had our technology
you know what I mean we've with
developer technology the assembly pocket
blockchain and the use case of it and
we've battled tested it against many
different blocking enthusiasts or the
brightest minds of what the you know the
study groups and the other these like
meetups or like these conferences
attendees have to offer regarding you
know as far as the blockchain technology
goes and you know like we've had no
problem impressing the entire audience
or anybody that we speak with regarding
the technology I think the the hardest
part as a company I guess with this
foundation from Korea that has to
experience starting our base in the
States
is the fact that you know we just don't
have much of like I guess I can network
that we can you know get plugged into in
a sense that we have an opportunity to
you know present in front of like I
guess like the the major players or the
larger VCS or any other the network
opportunity is what I think is the
biggest challenge that a lot of
companies who don't have as much of a
affiliation or the background in the
States has to go through and very lost
material thoughts right and you know I
think what SJ was saying earlier too is
that Korean government has recently been
issuing or putting a lot more effort
into supplying I guess the fundings to
get the startup ecosystem up and running
in Korea and while I think that is a
good approach in terms of like you know
the market itself the growth and the the
oversaturation of the market so that you
know there's more opportunity for
innovation and everything to grow while
I think that is a good idea for the
government's to actually start
supporting the ecosystem of like
entrepreneurship I think the the
challenges that is facing right now is
the lack of the no house in a sense that
it's not just about putting the money
into where where everything is building
up
I think from the government especially
because it is the government they try to
be fair and then they try to you know
distribute their resources equally to
pretty much a lot of the young
entrepreneurs whereas you know it's kind
of like you're taking a risk in a sense
that you starting like an early-stage
startups you don't know how many of
those are going to actually pan out so I
think I think from like the experiences
of the things like that a lot of the
better work can be done if the
government's actually take time to limit
and review and limit how they utilize
those resources
in a sense that you know I think more
money can be focused and support can be
focused and help the businesses to scale
rather than getting off the ground is I
think how not only from the government's
perspective but anybody in like a VC or
this ecosystem of you know associated
being associated with the
Entrepreneurship can better utilize
their I guess efficiency their input
versus output can be better made with
you know companies that have I guess
shown their usability feasibility both
to a certain expect extent yeah so our
focus going forward like we say you know
we decided that because you know instead
of like trying to figure out a way you
know trying to reach out to whoever and
anyone anyone whoever and anybody that
we thought the best use cases is
basically to basically go out there and
prove ourselves with the metrics in
whatever way that we can generate them
and you know using those metrics to
actually the use cases to to prove our
worth and you know get the recognition
and the inroads to the interest from the
connections that we currently don't have
rather than trying to figure out you
know how can we get in contact with
personal ABC so those are the challenges
that we're currently going through
but we're excited to take on as well and
to grow and becoming I guess like a
universal blocking solution would be
where we want to add that next that's
great thanks Brian thank you
so I tell you what I'd like to do s J
would you sit in the middle Brian you
sit there and I'll sit on the okay and
you know I got some questions I want to
ask before we get into the general
audience of discussion and starting off
with your own stories
okay so SJ you were a serial
entrepreneur in in Korea right in Seoul
while you were a student and after you
were a student and I'm curious where a
lot of your friends kind of amazed at
your decision to go the entrepreneurship
route yeah the thing is even if it's the
ecosystem itself grew much bigger when I
was in college
it's about year 2000 2005 and a few
years after that there weren't a lot of
people who are into the startups and
there wasn't even a word startup in
Korean equity later yeah they call the
venture venture company venture company
yeah so yeah my friends always thought
that I was like not normal yeah I was
unusual of them and what was it like to
put together the resources to get a
company started cause you gotta find
somebody reward with you and you also
have to find some money in Korea was
that really difficult
also for sent B was it really difficult
yes so all the years before Sam P I was
more into the creative area for my so
called items for my startup mm-hmm
the reason I chose a FinTech when
sturdy sent me was that I experienced a
lot of family before so I decided to go
with the trend and since when I started
the San P the FinTech was what breezes
are looking for to invest in so it was
really hard to focus money okay yeah so
the wave itself is important I think
that so what about getting people to
work with you so it's not the direct
answer but on what I learned why the
reason I learned to code is that because
it's not easy to meet people I mean work
with my project I want you to be able to
start my own project multiple times you
know it takes several tires to succeed
at least one of them so that's one of
the reasons and yeah it's not still not
easy to gather good people I mean talent
mm-hmm and it's also yeah I would ask
how to do yeah sure because actually you
know in what you're doing connecting
designers to customers the issue of
trust is a huge issue
yeah right I mean the designers have to
trust you that you're giving them good
opportunities and the big companies you
know are trusting you to be able to
introduce good designers how do you
establish that and I mean you talk about
a remote team that that's that's
probably the easy part to do remotely so
I I see that as a typical
chicken-and-egg problem and also one of
the reasons I chose design over
Development Award something others some
other areas is that as I mentioned in
the slides Korean designers are very
eager to find jobs so that made us for
us to gather designers somehow easier so
when you try it's been about the
several weeks since we actively started
looking for designers to work with and
yes some of them have their doubts but
they still come to us and ask for us to
join us yeah actually that the it's not
a goodness that their economies that bad
but for us it's an opportunity to solve
one of those chicken and egg problems
well and actually you're making a real
contribution if you can help people get
work during them yeah about the economy
so that's great
one more question before I put Brian on
the hot seat the last question for right
now is oK you've been five different
places around the world this past year
now yet though they're including the
places I'll visit this year right okay
including including places you will
visit how do you think you'll decide on
where you settle down
where will the company be located
eventually so the biggest advantage of
being a remote entrepreneur is that you
can settle it down anywhere you want to
do okay
but yeah honestly my my place he'll
settle down will be heavily dependent on
my wife's career path okay but if I if I
have choice I'd like to go where the
ocean is
and we're techies so actually this place
is perfect for me okay okay good thank
you very much for saying so Brian at
Berkeley right how did you decide on
kind of a startup company path instead
of the traditional route of going to
work for a big company right I mean it
was an opportunity that I came across me
as after upon I guess graduating as I
was you know interviewing for many
different opportunities that I could be
going into and it was really more about
a personal attachment for me I guess
the idea of utilizing you know this new
technology to create this like a new
channel of like a music distribution and
just a guest a charismatic persona of YT
that that I came upon whitey was is the
founder and CEO yes yes sorry he he
wanted to be here but then his business
trip got over extended I guess who can
so he couldn't attend the schedule and
well but I actually really wanted to
focus this session on people who are
more or less intentionally in the United
States and not back in the home country
right right um so he's going back and
forth and then basically he's more or
less the reason why he set his eyes on
on starting this business and I'm
focusing our efforts in the US market
was like I said earlier was because that
we want to you know be in the mist of
ulti ulti what you know to brightest
minds and see what opportunity just
other than the fact that it's a bigger
market compared to Korea but also it
just because we're dealing with I got
technological innovation yeah okay but
back to your own story so okay Berkeley
is a is a big elite school so did your
family give you a hard time when you
decided to go to a startup company
instead of take a big company job no
actually you know they've been they've
been very supportive that I you know
found something that I really like to do
actually okay it's not my I guess not my
startup but in a sense that that I found
value in what we were working on and you
know so it's pretty much like a first
time in a while they were anything that
I was super excited about doing as well
someone they took it as like an
opportunity for me to I guess start my
career working in with with a
entrepreneur company yes okay okay so
with regard to Yosemite
do you think you could do the same kind
of trial user acquisition and market
development in Korea that you can do
here I mean I realize there are reasons
why the companies here mm-hmm but user
acquisition getting people to try out
you know yosemite card and so forth
right actually it's actually been a much
more difficult test for us to be
tackling the US market as our as our go
to market strategy because of the fact
that like he's had like a long
experience of like of being a serial
entrepreneur himself you know like
fifteen years of businessmen he has like
a pretty good enough like a connection
and the networks that you can get plug
into it and get introduced to in korea
so it would grew a lot more easier path
if we actually just stayed and focused
in korean and with the possible wrinkle
of what you mentioned this day about the
you know the attitude toward government
regulation whereas here you know if if
the law doesn't specifically say you
can't do something people will try to do
it and it is kind of the opposite in
korea where you know if the law doesn't
allow you to do it specifically yeah
right but we during our course up the
action and we weren't specifically
dealing with i guess that got something
that was defined as like a you know not
illegal but something that was not
outright if life was a really question
yeah so it wasn't really a question of
like you know we're just gonna have a
better coverage here versus over there
it was just more about the the
opportunity that we decided to tackle
long as our main target in the states
well a peer-to-peer kind of credit card
is a really interesting idea and you
know blockchain is a really interesting
solution to making that happen
but yeah you must have a lot to do with
the up and down of even though you're
not cryptocurrency base
do you find that investor interest or
people interest in the company really
changes depending on so I mean obviously
yeah I mean obviously one of the one of
the one of the first questions that are
there being asking is like you know how
do you fare against like I get stuck in
purgatory bodies or whatever you know
trying to engage with I could
cryptocurrency as well as like this
whole like issue of like a credit card
system
I mean not to mention the fact that one
we don't have like a cryptocurrency that
are involved which are time targets of
what do you go to a parties are
concerned about regarding the technology
itself so we're not too worried or
concerned about that aspect but figuring
out the feasibility of it as akka I
guess like a new type of a payment
system and where the financial I guess
like a fence and where as far as I could
Vincent everybody's concern is what
you're you know working actively with
like art attorneys as well like a group
of advisers yeah one more about the card
so Yosemite receives some sort of a fee
for each transaction or how is that
going to work what's the business model
right so I mean our business model is it
comes from the fact that we are for
providing the ecosystem and the platform
for a lot of the merchants and the
customers to be connected to basically
we're buying a usable store balance from
the merchants directly and then you know
basically we're reselling that to the
customers and then we make I guess
margins between due to whereas like you
know how much basically the exact Costco
model we both buy in advance so that we
can actually provide that to and resell
that to the investor for the whole
ecosystem around the market
yeah it's just a mystery we just don't
have any as much intermediary services
that are involved yeah okay one last
question for both of you
I'm sort of the personal side so what
would you see as the ideal outcome for
your company
we talk a lot about exits in this class
but not necessarily exit if Yosemite is
wildly successful and if Apple is wildly
successful
what will the what will happen how do
you see what would you see in the future
say five years from now or ten years
from now do you think you will have an
exit be bought out by somebody or right
I mean granted that like I'm not the
final decision-maker this topic but I
think you freedom to talk but I think
the ideal situation would be for us to
be in a position where we are I guess
being bought out and you know like we're
not going to say I guess no to the fact
that there are interested parties who
are looking to buy us out in order to
integrate to their solutions or you know
things like that you know but it's not
the end of the road for us in a sense
that you know we want to provide you
know utilize the technology to generate
a solution in intact industry the second
goal was to make this happen
yeah so so our you know if you still in
court and and our current project is not
the the one and only goal for us so we
have you know series of other projects
that we are interested in tackling on
don't you other one in charge one at a
time yeah at all it will be like a
series of tackling these issues okay SJ
what about Apple so I see this as so
we'll keep working better at remote is
also a trend I think it's not a hot
potato ice block chain or other FinTech
area but it's a steady trend that so
yeah
other companies say that in year 2027
more than half of people we won't
remotely I mean in career as a
freelancers so I think I see this as a
steady trend and how we work will be
changed steadily mm-hmm so in five or
ten years later
I don't see what we are doing is
finished so I think I'll be still doing
this in more areas and in more different
ways
mm-hmm okay now this really is this is a
huge new possibilities in really how
work is done but there's a lot of things
to work out you know the areas where it
works well together in the areas where
yeah maybe more difficult okay why don't
we open the floor to audience questions
go ahead number of customers so SJ where
are where are your customers now the
people who are buying the design
services there in the United States so
mostly we are focusing on startups who
are who just hired the marketing people
or the for CMO so that they you start
content creation and ad creatives
actively and we can help them get
matched with a good cost-efficient
designers to be closer to your customer
what would it do is asking suggest I
thought was going to my head while you
were saying maybe you want to live it's
probably better to live closer to your
customer then further away from your
festival do you think that's going to be
a factor and where you decide to live
should you be close to the customers
physically ah so so my personal location
yes as a CEO I think I should be leave
as closest as possible to my clients so
that I could learn what they want
yeah okay
she said that he moved into syntek
because that was fashionable and he
thought he could get funding have you
bought into blockchain because it's
fashionable because it's not clear to be
what you are doing that's sufficiently
different that the blockchain should
make a live right um I mean I kind of
stayed away from going to super specific
details about you know how our you know
what we develop there's any of us
watching this different than the
traditional blockchain but to answer the
first question regarding you know
whether we're in it for D I guess a
fashionable reason that's not specific
ace I mean well I mean you know the
blockchain of course gives you the
ability to trace you can't edit a
transaction so can add on to further
information that maybe just solely part
of the phone I mean we're trying to
utilize the blockchain in a sense that
we can actually seamlessly efficiently
replace the how to process the
transactions or how the you know the
operation aspect of how the company runs
their businesses are are being done like
for example I mean talking about the
card or different tech regarding like a
financial institution perspective for
example a lot of the the cost goes into
the operations of you know how these
banks or financial institutions trying
to spend a lot of the money and
resources to maintain the security and
the validity of the database that they
have for allowing the financial
transactions to happen through their
platform blockchain as the technology
can innately replace the need of such
highly such a high cost of maintenance
because the technology is what allows
the security of the immutability or the
transparent transparency of of the
ledger can be basically subsidized with
the absence of the liability or under
excessive you know people can't deny
that they have ordered something right
so like it's immutable the the ledger
itself is like an immutable ledger so
that you know you can't hack it you
can't fake it mathematically it's been
proven - you can't fake transactions on
blotching yes okay but it is a you know
significant that the cryptocurrency
based blockchain companies all take
pieces of the blockchain as tokens and
those tend to act like currency items
like like coins or whatever but what
you're doing is really taking a
transaction right and attaching that as
a piece of the blockchain right so that
you can really guarantee what has been
moved from where to where I mean in a
sense that a lot of these that go out
there other public law changes they rely
on cryptocurrencies have to pay for like
the network fees and the usage fees with
the cryptocurrencies and that itself
would the volatility issue about the
price points is what causes the issues
from you know these businesses to even
consider using plotting as we personally
experienced when we first started it
before we were going to build our own
protocol is because it's just not
feasible in a sense so if somebody uses
a yosemite card basically they make a
purchase just like they would with a
regular card as long as the merchant
accepts it exactly I mean we're I mean
in our sense like the things that it
doesn't have to be the Dominator didn't
know yeah yeah we're just using the
blockchain is like a ledger book to
basically keep all the transactional
record and for I guess set on the
balances yeah okay good thank you next
question
go ahead work done I have two questions
one for a four and one for ATX my
question also is that although it's like
according to my understanding of
connecting their designers with the
companies so my my question was like for
companies who are looking for designers
do they go search on your website for
designers or do you have an algorithm to
calculate the suitable designers for
each company and you sent them an email
every day or like every week and
recommend suitable like designers for
those so currently we don't have a lot
of customers yet so we manually do that
but we don't let we don't open our
designers info on the website so that we
could manually suggest them so yeah this
is how it works if you sign up as client
we recommend designers but not using the
algorithm just yet maybe in the future
but we do that manually but you can
choose between like two to three
designers we suggest and then you can
work with their questions because you're
talking about like a blockchain us a way
of safer transfer of many currencies so
my question is not also like for example
the MasterCard and Visa are turning
their attention to like like blockchain
issues and also like master cut a
MasterCard launched appropriate project
a blockchain project in 2016 like to
improve the use of blotching and they're
like currency transfer business and they
currently own like thirty percent of
full like blockchain related like
patents so I'm wondering what kind of
edge do you have against like such big
Catholic companies like MasterCard or
Visa well our key advantage compared to
I mean yes they have more money and
resources than us and they have they may
have more
than us and stuff like that but our key
advantage comes from the fact that you
know the master cars and the likes of
master cars and these companies that are
trying to utilize blockchain for their
you know company usages are still trying
to rely and depend their usages of the
existing technologies and our conclusion
came from the fact that because the
existing technologies are not viable for
any like a real business case adoption
is why we decided to create our own
protocol that can actually move away
from the network's reliance on native
cryptocurrency the reason why I keep
going back to the cryptocurrencies stuff
is because that's in my personal opinion
is what is the biggest hindrance or the
hurdle that the companies have yet to
overcome in order before being able to
produce something it is that it's
feasible again it's this is just my
personal opinion but for any business to
actually use blockchain they have to pay
the network fee in ether or eos token or
build native cryptocurrency and when the
when that network fee is depending
dependent on the price volatility or
subject to the price volatility I mean
the price of ether for example in the
past year it went jump up and down like
four hundred percent right at one point
it was like almost like two thousand
something dollars and then now it's like
almost like two hundred dollars so if I
as a business have to pay with ether
that may be worth hundred dollars
tomorrow and you know fifty dollars the
next day or two hundred like I can't
it's not a reasonable projection I can't
come up with any like a reasonable
projection on in terms of like how much
I have to account for in my usages of
this server like services which is why
we decided to shift away from any like a
volatility issue and strictly use the
technology for what it's worth so Brian
I want to add just the thing you talked
a lot about how
your approach to blockchain is different
from other approaches to blockchain but
in answer to one John's question a big
company has a business model and visa
has you know made its business based on
a percentage of every transaction and if
what you're doing can undercut that
percentage by eliminating a lot of the
middle people and not having to have a
local bank also guarantee the
transaction then you can really disrupt
the credit card business and it's very
unlikely for an existing credit card
company to disrupt its own business
oh well two questions about you some of
the X and I'm sorry these are very basic
because I'm not thanks for watching
following on the professor - are saying
what is the value proposition do some DX
abuse on the X card from both a consumer
and for a merchant are you simply trying
to decrease the security cost which
would point toward pick an acquisition
by a credit card company are you
potentially trying to you know lower
drastically lower keys to make it more
advantageous for a merchant or something
to make it advantageous more
advantageous for a consumer it would
edge might point towards actually
replacing credit cards first and then
you can ask the other one yeah so
specific about your summary card is the
fact that we're talking to the merchants
um to basically accept your seventy card
instead of you know any other payment
method because this way you can actually
don't have to pay you know on average a
lot of these businesses are paying
anywhere between three and five percent
per transaction to be taken by Visa
MasterCard and all the other
intermediary services and we can process
them we don't charge any of the
transaction fees so they won they can
actually sir save the cost of the
transaction but also we're coming up
with
if you saw that on the screen earlier is
that basically it's an app so like a lot
of the customers who are local can
search for which of the merchants are
you know on Yosemite card and is
offering the rewards what we're
suggesting to the merchants is basically
use this as like a marketing platform
for them to you know promote their
businesses and be like hey you know what
using your seminary part in because
we're saving the cost of the
transactions and all this stuff
we're actually giving back you know like
a cash back service to to the to the
consumers who come in and buy from us
you know and and because of the on top
of what whatever this reward program
like a stamp card for example is like
buy one buy by 10k one free kind of a
thing can be translated into like a cash
back service so that hey you know you
fly with your similar card you get 10%
15% 20% cash back to the consumer side
is a lot more advantages than whatever
credit card they can get on the market
because most credit cards especially to
you know people who are just starting
off after college or whatever they're
not subject to the high-end work or the
car but they're more or less getting
like one to three percent cashback so
because we were able to offer a platform
where merchants can't directly market to
the customers directly by offering
higher rewards it's kind of like a
win-win situation for both parties to
use the seminary card instead of relying
on the old legacy payment rails okay
good it's a good question that's the
thanks I get out so the the merchants
it's zero the merchants are gonna be
charged zero or close to zero percent
like for transaction image mm-hmm
somehow and how what is the benefit to
your company and how is this cash
where's this cash back coming from so
the cash prizes are coming from directly
from the merchants who are offering and
using you know basically from merchants
and it's kind of like they're taking
this as a converting opportunity so
whatever
why
getting cost they partner with a third
party marketing companies or promotional
stamp cards that they're already
offering right now we're just trying to
solidify that into or simplify that by
you give it as a cash back to your
customers and we make money based and as
I guess a platform provider to one is
like I said earlier was the margin
between how much they're giving us for
how much I guess like a cash back there
willing to participate in and from the
group of the users that we have like
their customers there's a coconut to
tears like between like a premium
customers and the regular customers
let's say the merchants are offering
like all twenty percent cashback then
the premium users are going to be the
one is able to get up to 20 percent like
all twenty percent and the the regular
members are earning twelve percent so
that we can margin eyes on that a
presenting between for the regular
people regular members so the secreto
the other just basic question is I'm
aware as an on blockchain expert that
things like Bitcoin are gigantic drain
on energy supplies in terms of mining
bitcoins does that only apply to a
cryptocurrency and not to this kind of a
use of logic so that applies to Bitcoin
specifically and the older generations
of like the public box chains because
that that energy draining problem has to
do with the fact that they're reliant on
like a proof-of-work which is how the
network as a whole reach consensus we
developed like a proof of transaction as
I got our own consensus mechanism which
does not require as crazy over resources
I mean we can talk about it I mean
you've given the the saturation of the
time that we have we can talk about it
afterwards but I'll be more happy to
answer that in more detail
okay before before we go on and say I
want to follow up because what you were
talking about Brian is really kind of
what is distinctive about your approach
and so barriers to entry for other
people who might be trying to do the
same thing
SJ in what you're doing what is the real
kind of competitiveness for Apple to
make sure that somebody like you know a
big HR firm or LinkedIn or somebody like
that can't just you know run you out of
business
yeah that's a good question so we I see
the offer I give as is too big thing but
the first one is the market of
cost-efficient designers and I I think
since as I mentioned Korean designers
are looking for jobs and they are very
talented it can be a competitive
advantage in the beginning and actually
the second part is the collaboration
tool itself mm-hmm
that helps the communication between
designers and known designers and I
think it has more potential in the long
term mm-hm
even in these days when you are working
with designers you it's not easy because
they they use their own jargon and they
have their own expressions they work
their way of expressions it's and I can
also imagine that from the point of view
of the designer most clients are very
funny and what they say though yes yes
so we are trying to solve those kind of
problems in sideout platform and also we
have planned to make it publicly
available or even for other platforms so
yeah and I I think learning of people
are very interested in about solving
those kind of professionals and those
kind of communication issues between
professionals and
non-professionals maybe maybe implosion
as well you know you don't have to know
everything about blockchain to talk
about the pieces but you have to know at
least that specs or you should be able
to convey the information you'd like to
know but since you don't understand you
don't fully understand the blockchain
you cannot ask the right question right
yeah so I think all areas that requires
professionalizing that can be our
technical on one side and not technical
on the other yeah
ok great I saw a couple of hands over
here you first
yeah my name is Chris and I'm co-founder
of opal I'm just uh
Jericho support my CEO but I have a
question to Brian
specifically so maybe you said this and
I just you know wasn't paying attention
fully but my question was what's really
in it for the customers customers buying
merchandise using your card is it just
the exclusive rewards you get through
that partnership that you have with the
merchants or is there more to it first
of all it will be the more direct way of
asking that is yes it is because using
using any part they're able to earn much
more force than what they would
otherwise use with I guess like a basic
credit card compared to like that 150
percent cash back offer that typically a
lot of big regular 30% at the same part
as you know you know it ranges between
merchants but anywhere from five to
sometimes even up to thirty percent
cashback that variables aren't so that
yeah main reason why you might would use
because it's more official for that okay
is there is there right now are you are
you running a pilot with close group of
you know shell users or so we hold up
the the initial technology to basically
should work out I guess the kinks and
then
in a closed thing and we are currently
working with acquiring the early
adopters to be able to work with them
upon our official launch comic day at
1:00 so that means you've got some
customers on users and you've also got
some merchants on you who will have
expressed their their willingness to
fund emergent site to participate and
you know offer 20 or 30 percent 20
percent 30 percent cash back to it their
customers this is in a way it's very
much Lean Startup movement kind of you
know minimally Viable Product and get it
out there and get market feedback do you
think that YT or anybody else connected
with the company intentionally tried to
follow the Lean Startup model or is this
just sort of natural well in a sense
think we were this is this has been our
I guess I got go to market strategy yeah
um because of the fact that you know we
didn't have much to I guess like prove
ourself from the get-go so we weren't
like you know what this is what we have
instead of taking a lot a long time to
basically meeting the right partner
meeting the right people to basically
showcase what we can do that just prove
it with our with what we can do which is
basically the hands-on approach that we
want to go out there and get the
generate results ourselves okay yeah
good Jerry I saw your hand Network how
big is it right now how many notes
oh no so basically you just so many
probably blockchain that it it it it
went my call months ago and all the
other notes that are being tested are
you know not tested but initially those
are part of
our selves - basically the service
providers that are going to be using the
network is going to be what the formal
team that knows in the buffer research
of the network so right now it's not
that big in a sense that we only have a
very limited my public so mark Shane
right now in a sense yes but before we
can actually because we don't have like
the crypto currently because we didn't
do an IC o---- we didn't have like a
cryptocurrency to like generate a lot
interest from these businesses by giving
away those tokens so we wanted to first
provide the feasibility and the
usability prove the usability of the
network by creating a service and
running that to basically create a use
case statement that hey your semi block
block chain is actually viable so that
we can actually invite a lot of the
enterprise partners that we are
currently in talks with to be able to
give them I guess like a sense of a
reason to understand how they can use
this to me to public boxing's to better
their business you're talking whatsit
peg - so what the thing is like we don't
have our token okay there's no one like
your similarly token it's like a
fundamentally different concept of like
how the traditional poor team works but
basically all the block producers are
going to be made up of all the service
providers who are already generating
their sales and their service using
using the blocking as a as a their
system so because they're already an
active participant on the network their
incentive to become a block producer is
not to earn tokens or not to earn money
from it but in order to make sure that
their activity can sustain can be
sustained over time over a period of
time is their incentive to participate
in making sure that blocks are being
produced in the correct way and making
sure that all - you know there's nothing
going
since they said not to get too much
under the technicalities with blockchain
I would like to point out that last year
in our programs we featured a company
that was joint between here in Shanghai
that was doing something very similar
really sort of blockchain version 3.0
you know - the current cryptocurrency
for data from automobiles and the
company's name was car block and I think
they're still quite active as a totally
different kind of use case where data
from automobiles could be traded and the
blockchain really enabled the cars to do
the trading and the owners just to get
the results so there are all sorts of
new ideas in this area out and one thing
that attracted me to Yosemite is that
this is a new kind of generation of
blockchain it's really a new use of the
whole technology approach I want to ask
both of you what do you miss about Korea
well I'm going back to Korea next week
so okay so nothing it too much but yeah
so when I'm in Korea I have my own
network even in startups and I know
investors my old friends doing startups
as well so those kind of active
discussions like I have today mm-hmm I
can have a lot of that and that's maybe
the one that one thing I miss okay Brian
for me it would have to be the fact any
like my parents are in Korea and I don't
get to see them as often I guess as I
would have been if I were stationed in
Korea I guess yeah you know we get to
see each other probably like a couple
times a year maybe huh yeah another
question kind of about Korea both of you
talked about Korean government money
yeah from the standpoint of the
entrepreneur how do you apply for this
stuff I mean if if you're Korean and
you're an entrepreneur how do you find
out about the event
ability of the government money and do
you have to go through a private sector
investor or do you go straight and apply
for a government grant like a small
business grant you have both ways
so most of Korean in Breezy investors
they use government money to fund the
startups and there are a lot of grant
programs in Korea actually there are too
many of them so that there's us all
dedicate startup - I mean curate those
informations and feed them to the set
ups and let you know which one is for
yours and which one isn't for years you
know so yeah those like those kind of
sources are what we use okay yeah I
personally don't have a capture
experience myself with it but as to my
understanding that a lot of this even
the private sectors fundings are coming
from the government subsidized money
that their governments are giving to the
private sectors be like hey you can use
this to support you know the the
startups and you know invest in them so
I was told that it's not like much of a
difficult task to I mean at least get in
touch with them I guess a comment that
that we as far as I know is the fact
that the the use of the money the use of
the fund could be better regulated or
better organized I guess so this is kind
of a really broad question but for both
of you this is one thing that is a
feature of the Korean system right now
is this government money are you seeing
what kind of changes are you seeing
really in the last year - in the startup
sort of world in Korea are there a lot
more thanks to this money or are people
saying yeah maybe you ought not to take
this or what what's happening are we
getting a lot more startup companies
yeah I think the startup scene is
growing very rare to be fala as I
briefly mentioned in my site there are
pros and cons
if you feed money to all start up the
syrup there should be that they survive
and I'm not sure if if how that's
capitalism words and how they're your
favorite air this is not an interesting
country and investing profits right so
yeah but you know I see a lot of
interesting interesting setups doing
very different trials and yeah it it
makes it more it gives it gives more
chance to see a success points Brian are
you staying in touch with friends or
family childhood friends in Korea and
are you seeing any changes and attitudes
or trends and entrepreneurship I mean I
mean you know I think something from the
news even I think we can hear a lot more
of like the startups that are starting
that are growing in market in general
which i think is a good thing and i
think what needs to be done is a better
way of utilizing that program you know
like what st just mentioned you know if
we equally distribute and $100,000
almost like a hundred companies first is
you know we could subsidize a million
dollar for ten you know
proven companies that could be a lot
more resource that is utilized to the
right direction and putting to better
use quite frankly speaking so I mean I
think that could come I guess with
experience of you know how the launch of
this program can further develop into go
ahead
foreigners and the role that they play
in the startup ecosystem in South Korea
so I was wondering if you know if there
are how many foreigners actually are
working in these startups you know do
they have a chance to play an important
role are some of them in c-level
positions and this could include like
members of the Korean to ask for us or
Korean Americans as well and even though
the government has started a fund a very
large fund I it doesn't seem like they
have made a lot of efforts to make the
legal side easier for foreigners to work
in Korea so I was wondering if that has
changed mhm
sorry I not to shy away from it but
that's something that I'm not really
aware of or in a position to comment
anything about so yeah sure you don't
know that yeah so when I was in Stampede
the sentry was actually helping
Southeast Asian people to send their
money back to their country so we had to
hire Southeast Asian employees to help
for the CS and yeah as yeah I think the
case is different if the company is
seeing the market in the United States
or and other overseas countries were the
companies focusing on the Korean market
if the company is currently focusing on
the Korean market I don't think you have
good chance of working in that company
as a foreigner because they use Korea
and they talk in Korean and they don't
have any reason to communicate in
foreign language but if it's the other
case I think you have good chance to
work in Korean startup cetera but I also
I'm not I wasn't a person who were
responsible for the visa of the
employees in our company it was a nice
but it was possible I think it's a
little bit easier than the state so yeah
if
you have the skillsets the company ones
I think you can find the job you're
looking for in the Korean so I also like
to comment on this over the years we've
had foreigners who live in Korea and
have done startup companies and have
moved over to the venture investing side
so these people do exist of course there
are small numbers of people but what you
say about you know a lot of unemployed
designers you know those are skilled
people and so if the condition in the
country is is unemployment from key
people like college graduates then
definitely that's going to be a big
objective for government policy is to
solve that problem and I think that's
probably what's going on with the
current situation right now that the
real sort of domestic the mccr attak
government problem that they have to
deal with is is unemployment and so this
is you know trying to stimulate more
startup companies as the way I think
let's call it into the formal part of
the discussion we've got some
refreshments outside of and hope that
you'll stay around and talk with our
speakers and talk with each other a
little bit outside but first please join
me in thanking SJ and Brian for a great
[Applause]